the start pretty much borderline
disastrous for Antonio Brown in New
England because of a serious off field
complication we spoke at length about
yesterday he was at practice later in
the day wearing number one because
they've yet to issue him an actual
number I think he really wants a where
number 84 that belongs to Ben Watson
they've yet to get that all worked out
but that is nothing in comparison to the
bigger issue that is hovering over
Antonio Brown and the New England
Patriots the civil lawsuit for sexual
assault and rape the NFL investigating
the NFL due to speak to the accuser
Brittany Taylor next week Chris
yesterday had the involvement of others
this is why coaches and and sometimes I
think the word distraction gets used as
cover for I just don't want that guy
because of whatever the thing is that
I'm calling a distraction right but we
saw yesterday that it does create a
distraction because your teammates your
head coach they get asked about the
thing that is related to you it has
nothing to do with them and they have to
spend time worrying about it and talking
about yeah I mean that's exactly the
point that syllable teams don't want to
deal with and especially out of all the
teams in the NFL we know the New England
Patriots are the team you know more than
anyone that wants to limit distractions
they're so not into the media fanfare
anything it's all about business all
about play all about the day's challenge
that's ahead practice dominate the
meetings that are so focused and I have
to answer these kind of things I'm sure
is annoying for Belichick and Brady but
at the same time there'd still be a lot
of questions even if this didn't go down
with Antonio Brown people wanted to ask
about his you know just fitting in there
this takes it to another level it's put
a national scope on the issue it's for
the national scope on mr. Kraft the New
England Patriots in a bad way and I
think that's probably really annoying to
you know the higher-ups and that
organization as well
yeah the scope was placed on Bill
Belichick yesterday when he met with the
media here is some of what Belichick had
to say when he was pressed fairly
aggressively by reporters to talk about
the Antonio Brown situation here's
Belichick
how difficult or frustrating because you
have a discretion like to sweat at the
beginning of the season yeah we're gonna
work on Miami or work on the rest of it
is it's well - you've had bigger
distractions before you confident that
this is not gonna we're working on my
own went through the scouting report
went through the game plan today we're
gonna practice her mine yeah I mean I'm
done with that
okay anything else on Miami other
questions I just answered that question
actually I did okay and that was that a
very short press conference yesterday
for Bill Belichick because look they
wanted him to talk about Antonio Brown
he wasn't interested in talking about
Antonio Brown that's how you limit
distractions though right there because
it's a no story I mean they just note
there's no bullet or bulletin board
material he says that his team sees him
say those kind of the things so they
become robots in the answer as well and
if you wanted to diffuse distractions
nobody does it better than New England
that's how you diffuse it there's no
quotes there's nothing to talk about and
you know here we are just trying to talk
about Antonio Brown but we can't do
anything about what Bill Belichick said
well Bill Belichick didn't give us
anything that advances the story I did
notice that performance it allows us to
dissect that but yeah in the building
right and I guess from Antonio Browns
perspective right he has to appreciate
and respect the fact that Bill Belichick
said as little as possible about his
situation it's just different here
because this if these allegations are
even remotely true this is a serious
situation that's where I think it
becomes a little problematic and I know
some people around the league who think
that maybe Belichick should have struck
a different tone and I know how he is
and I know what he does in that setting
it is a military exercise where you keep
everything close to your vest and you
don't want to tip your hand on anything
and you want to say as little as
possible because anything you say can
undermine your broader objectives for
that week
given the subject matter it I think some
people would have preferred a different
facade a different right you still don't
have to answer the question you can
still say the same things but that hard
edge that he always has I don't know how
you soften it when you never have
anything but that hard edge when you're
meeting with the media I just think the
subject matter makes it delicate and
complicated far more complicated than a
situation where someone's peppering me
with questions about a knee injury oh
yeah I mean you're right about that you
know I guess what do they like to see a
little bit of a softer side or more
remorse or what you know just for the
severity of the charges and things like
that I mean I understand that totally
and don't get it messed up Bill's a
stand-up human being I mean he's he
certainly takes these allegations
seriously he does I mean he's not into
the mistreatment of people and you could
just tell that would the way Bill
Belichick treats people I mean he he
just as we've heard Rodney Harrison say
he does not judge anyone if you've made
mistakes in the past okay he takes him
to an account but when he gets you in
there he does give you a fresh slate and
tries to you know okay this is this is
here this is with me this is how he's
acting with me so I know he takes the
allegation serious but his job is still
to be the head coach of the New England
Patriots and get his team ready and when
it comes to press conference that's kind
of part of his job and getting the team
ready to and he treats it with the same
manner that he does anything else it
wasn't just Bill Belichick who spoke to
the media yesterday quarterback Tom
Brady had to face the questions and he
was as interested as Belichick was and
talking about the subject here's Brady
from Wednesday just answer that I'm just
trying to Chauvin play football and try
to prepare I'm he's a good team might
get ready for them and things that don't
involve me don't involve me that was Tom
Brady yesterday and look I'm from his
perspective he he really he really isn't
in a position to say anything it's
really not his job I don't know that
he's the one that you want to ask those
but this is what happens in a situation
like this everybody who gets put behind
a microphone is going to be asked these
questions alright real quickly on on
this before we move on the NFL is
investigating will Brown play on Sunday
that is an open question I think
ultimately the NFL can do whatever it
wants to do it's got the power to put
him on the commissioner exempt list
Chris and and if all else fails maybe
the Patriots decide he's not ready to
play and they can defer all of this
until next week when they meet with his
accuser reportedly that's when the
meeting is going to happen Britney tail
are gonna talk to the NFL next week and
then maybe the league will get some
clarity and can make a decision about
what did or didn't happen
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports